en el último vídeo vimos como las bases
con jugadas pueden estabilizarse por
inducción y también nos adentramos un
poquito en el tema de los orbitales que
será el enfoque de este vídeo así que
repasemos el concepto del cual hablamos
en el último vídeo donde teníamos tres
distintos estados de hibridación del
carbono y que cada una de esos de esos
estados de hibridación tienen distintas
electro negatividades que pueden afectar
la estabilidad de la base conjugada así
que hablamos hablamos de como estos tres
ácidos carboxílicos es una medida que
nos movemos a la derecha de hecho
podemos poner esta flecha que hemos
estado poniendo siempre a medida que nos
movemos a la derecha aumentaba la acidez
es verdad de tal suerte que la molécula
del ácido propiónico está que tenemos
aquí a la derecha es la más ácida de las
tres verdad y dijimos que eso tenía que
ver con los distintos estados de
hibridación de las moléculas de carbono
así que por ejemplo estos dos primeros
estos dos
tienen una hibridación sp3 estos dos
carbonos tienen una hibridación sp2 y
estos dos últimos carbonos tienen una
hibridación sp
ahora los carbonos con hibridación esp
son los que tienen una mayor electro
negatividad de estos tres así que
incluso aún siendo el mismo leve
elemento que es el carbono en la
hibridación esp es mayor o más bien el
electro negatividad del carbono y con
hibridación esp es mayor que la de
hibridación sp2 y ésta a su vez es mayor
que la que tiene hibridación sp3 verdad
entonces esta fue la el último caso el
de la derecha fue el más electro
negativo
y bien podemos pensar sobre el efecto
que esto tiene en la estabilidad de la
base conjugada cuando vemos que cuando
cuando algo tiene más electro
negatividad es entonces cuando hay un
efecto digamos de de atracción de
electrones de atracción de electrones ok
entonces si pensamos sobre sobre la
donación de este protón digamos en este
caso este es el protón ha sido verdad si
donamos este protón tenemos esta
molécula que queda con una carga
negativa en este oxígeno de aquí así que
tenemos esa carga negativa y simplemente
vamos a irnos un poquito rápido a esta
carga negativa se puede
digamos estar es localizada en esta
porción de la molécula ahora bien como
tenemos este este triple enlace o esta
hibridación esp entonces tendrá la
capacidad de atraer electrones y así
esta carga negativa no sólo está
deslocalizando en esta zona sino puede
irse un poquito más allá en este digamos
en esta otra porción de la molécula
de hecho concluyamos que mientras más
deslocalizamos la carga más estable se
volvía la base con jugada y mientras más
estable fuera la base con jugada más
ácida es la molécula así que todo esto
tiene que ver con las distintas electro
negatividades ahora vamos a aplicar el
mismo concepto a las acidez
a la acidez relativa de estas tres
moléculas verdad de estas perdón de
estas tres moléculas que tengo acá abajo
así que a la izquierda tenemos el etano
el beta no tiene un valor pk
aproximadamente de 50 en medio tenemos
el eterno que tiene un valor pk
aproximadamente de 44 entonces como
puedes darte cuenta ya estamos
aumentando en la acidez es verdad y
finalmente el latino tiene un pecado
aproximadamente de 25 entonces
nuevamente puedes observar que hay esta
tendencia de aumentar la acidez si nos
movemos hacia la derecha verdad
aumentando
acidez
y esto en realidad más bien tiene que
ver con la hibridación verdad por
ejemplo si nos fijamos en este carbono
verdad este por supuesto es nuestro
protón ácido entonces este es el protón
que vamos a donar y el carbono al cual
está unido tiene una hibridación esp 3
sp3 verdad por otro lado en lt no
digamos si éste es nuestro protón que
vamos a donar el carbono el cual está
unido éste tiene una hibridación sp2 y
finalmente si consideramos este como el
protón que se va a donar entonces el
carbono al cual está unido tiene una
hibridación s&p verdad entonces si
nosotros dibujamos las bases las bases
conjugadas por supuesto vamos a tener
que observar que este como es el ácido
más fuerte entonces su base conjugada
tiene que ser la más estable verdad
entonces si dibujamos la base conjugada
por ejemplo del etano
simplemente copia mos toda la molécula
este primer carbono tiene tres
hidrógenos este segundo carbono tiene
dos hidrógenos y quedarán dos electrones
en esta parte verdad y como se quedan
los electrones aquí tenemos una carga
negativa formando un carbón verdad este
este par de electrones simplemente van a
ocupar un orbital y el s&p 3 verdad y un
orbital con hibridación sp3 porque está
formado por un orbital ese y tres
orbitales p así que tenemos un 25 por
ciento del tipo s verdad y 75 por ciento
del tipo p así que los orbitales p son
mucho más grandes así que podríamos
pensar esto como que se encuentra en un
orbital relativamente grande y voy a voy
a exagerar lo simplemente para que se
vea claro que es lo que quiero decir con
esto verdad así que este par de
electrones sobre este carbón ocupan un
orbital con hibridación s
vamos adelante y vamos a dibujar la base
con jugada del eterno verdad entonces
nuevamente prácticamente copiamos
nuestra molécula a este cargo a este
carbono le corresponden dos hidrógenos a
este último le corresponde uno y
tendremos ahora dos electrones
solitarios con una carga negativa verdad
nuevamente tenemos un carbón en este
caso esta pareja de electrones
solitarios va a ocupar un orbital con
hibridación sp2 y un orbital con
hibridación sp2 viene de un orbitales y
dos orbitales pp así que tenemos digamos
33% de los orbitales tipo s verdad
del tipo ese y aquí me falta poner es
aproximadamente tendremos como un 67 por
ciento del tipo p así que como tenemos
más tipo s los orbitales s son más
pequeños así que podríamos pensar que el
orbital digamos que van a tener estos
electrones va a ser un poco más pequeño
va a ser grande pero no tan grande como
en el caso anterior verdad ahora vamos a
tratar de analizar el último caso del
del tino así que dibujamos su base con
jugada tenemos esta parte
lo pinté mal verdad en realidad es el
carbono unido con otro carbono a través
de un enlace triple este está unido a un
hidrógeno y éste finalmente tiene un par
de electrones solitarios verdad ahora
este carbono tiene una hibridación esp
así que va a tener una carga negativa
aquí verdad esto es un carbón y los
electrones solitarios ocupan un orbital
con hibridación esp y un orbital con
hibridación esp está formado por un
orbital ese y un orbital p y por lo
tanto tenemos del tipo s un 50% verdad
del tipo s y un 50 por ciento del tipo p
nuevamente los orbitales s son más
pequeños así que este orbital con
hibridación va a ser todavía más pequeño
de los dos que dibujamos anteriormente
más o menos algo así
y como él hace el propi no tiene el
menor de los valores pecas verdad aquí
lo podemos ver tiene un valor de 2025 el
propi no es el más ácido de estos tres y
por lo tanto su base con jugada de que
es esta molécula que pintamos aquí debe
ser la más estable verdad que esta de
aquí es la más estable y allí hay de
hecho hay muchas distintas explicaciones
de por qué esta base es la más estable
yo pienso que la más simple es y es
justamente la de la electro negatividad
así que si tenemos un carbonos con
hibridación esp debido a que son más
electro negativos digamos por ejemplo si
nos fijamos en esta molécula este
carbono de aquí este carbono de aquí
tiene una hibridación esp y por lo tanto
es más el electro negativo que si por
ejemplo nos fijamos en los que tienen
hibridación sp2 y podríamos pensar por
ejemplo también que los electrones que
se encuentran en este enlace tiene
e
no más bien estos electrones que se
encuentran en este enlace puedes pensar
como que se están moviendo en esta
dirección verdad justamente por la
electro negatividad esta está jalando
los electrones mucho más que por ejemplo
los que tienen hibridación esp o sp2
verdad y ya y eso hace sentido de porque
esta base conjugada es mucho más estable
que los otros ejemplos otra forma de
explicarlo podría ser pensar en los
electrones en los orbitales s que están
mucho más cerca del núcleo y por lo
tanto estos electrones en los orbitales
s sienten la carga positiva del núcleo
más que los electrones en los orbitales
p que tienen una mayor probabilidad de
estar lejos y por lo tanto es más es
pueden estabilizar más la carga negativa
los del tipo s de la base conjugada así
que estos l sus electrones más bien
están más cerca del núcleo y sienten esa
carga positiva mucho más verdad otra
forma también de explicarlo podría ser
utilizando la energía ya que los
vitales s están más cerca del núcleo que
los orbitales p entonces los electrones
en los orbitales s tienen una menor
energía y por lo tanto los electrones en
un orbital esp tienen menor energía
verdad que los electrones en los
orbitales sp2 o los sp3 entonces podemos
decir que los electrones son son los más
estables en un orbital esp ya no importa
realmente cómo lo veas hay muchas
maneras de pensar esto para mí yo creo
que es suficiente pensarlo con la
electro negatividad pero bueno por
supuesto hay muchas explicaciones más
avanzadas verdad y la cosa importante es
tener una idea general de las tendencias
en las ideas cuando nos fijamos en los
distintos estados de hibridación del
carbono que está unido a nuestro protón
ácido